public sénat en partenariat avec la ffb
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jacqueline gourault ministre auprès du
ministre de l'intérieur est l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir madame
gourou bonsoir et merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté donc notre invitation pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec les
échos radio classique et la fp
représenter ce soir par charlotte
gauthier et polo bria bonsoir à tous
deux merci également d'être là madame la
ministre vous allez répondre à trois
grandes questions premièrement sur le
terrorisme bien sûr comment empêcher les
individus fichés s ou fish et
radicalisée de passer à l'action
de qui va payer la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation et puisque c'est plus
de 26 milliards d'euros qu'il faut
trouver enfin iii et comme ministre du
modem est ce que vous avez comme
françois bayrou d impatience sur le
volet social de la politique engagée est
suivi par le chef de l'état et le
gouvernement
la première question tout de suite va
vous être vous est proposée par paul
briat
[Musique]
bonsoir jacqueline gourault deux jours
après l'attaqué au coeur de paris une
attaque au couteau
comment empêcher les individus fichés s
de passer à l'action
c'est très difficile d'éviter ce genre
d'événement on sait très bien qu'on ne
peut pas mettre des polices et derrière
chaque personne et que des actes isolés
comme celui ci sont difficilement
contrôlables d'art d'ailleurs beaucoup
de pays l'ont déjà éprouvée si je puis
dire
la france bien sûr on se rappelle de
marseille mais aussi la finlande
l'allemagne à hambourg alors on ne peut
pas ceux d'autres l'angleterre bien se
contenter de nom jean scot d'un puissant
je ne dis pas que c'est comment dire
c'est pas parce que ça se passe aussi
ailleurs qu'on doit je dirais se
consoler parce que d'abord c'est un
événement très grave et si vous le
permettez je vais d'abord dire aussi un
mot pour les familles d'abord la famille
du jeune homme qui est décédé
et puis les autres pour bien sûr ceux
qui sont blessés
je pense aussi aux policiers qui ont
fait preuve d'un grand courage d'une
grande réaction
et en même temps bien évidemment on doit
sans cesse se dire qu'il faut davantage
de moyens
c'est ce que nous avons décidé déjà en
décidant de renforcer les services de
renseignement vous savez qu'il va y
avoir près de 2000 personnes qui vont
être embauchés dans les services de
renseignement dont 450 cette année qu'il
va y avoir pendant le quinquennat dix
mille policiers et gendarmes qui vont
renforcer les forces de sécurité que il
y a aussi des attentats qui ont échoué
par le travail du renseignement et des
policiers
l'information sur justement les
tentatives qui ont échoué qui ont été
déjouées par les forces de sécurité oui
bien sûr oui il y a eu à peu près 22
attentats qui ont été déjoués dans les
15 derniers mois ce qui n'est pas rien
ça veut dire des morts évitées
évidemment mais effectivement et
j'entends aussi toutes les critiques les
polynies les polémiques pardon qui
peuvent naître ici ou là d'une certaine
manière dans un camp on le voit plutôt à
droite on va écouter d'ailleurs virginie
calmels ce qu'est la numéro deux des
républicains et qui interpelle le
gouvernement
on a le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui et bien
le gouvernement la france n'a pas pris
les mesures et notamment dans le domaine
juridique
l'arsenal juridique que nous avons est
celui d'un pays en paix alors que nous
nous considérons nous sommes en guerre
nous sommes en guerre contre l'état
islamique nous pensons qu'il faut
désigner le mal
ce qui n'est pas fait toujours dans la
classe politique on met un voile pudique
on parle d' attaque on parle d'agression
là on a on doit désigner le mal et on
doit le combattre et j'ai du mal à
entendre des responsables politiques
nous dire en gros il va falloir
s'habituer on peut rien faire on peut
pas anticiper ou finalement ça va se
reproduire alors que répondez vous à
cela
c'est plus à la demande d'un
renforcement de l'arsenal juridique
d'abord je ne sais plus très bien où et
virginie cas le même sens ce moment
d'ailleurs je m'interrogeais en
l'écoutant et en l'entendant l'arsenal
juridique il a été complétée par la loi
de sécurité que nous avons votée
récemment à la fin de l'année pour
renforcer les moyens justement hors du
temps
l'état d'urgence et ceci permet vous le
savez de mettre en place des périmètres
de protection de surveiller plus
attentivement les lieux de culte vous
savez également offert de surveillance
individuelle donc beaucoup de choses ont
été mises en place il semble que ne soit
pas assez pour l'opposition qui à chaque
attentat c'était déjà la même chose pour
trèbes
il y à un mois et demi revienne à la
charge pour vous demander des mesures
plus fermes interne et de manière
préventive les fichiers les plus
dangereux je vais vous dire qu'ils n'ont
pas la nationalité française crée un
délit d'incitation à la haine de la
france
expulser les étrangers qui s'en rendent
coupables aient refusé aussi le retour
des djihadistes revenant d'irak de syrie
qu'est ce que vous leur répondre je leur
réponds qu'il y a un an qu'emmanuel
macron et élus que edouard philippe et
premier ministre et que quand il y a eu
des événements qui ont lieu dans les
années précédentes
que ce soit sous la présidence de
françois hollande ou sous la présidence
de nicolas sarkozy
j'appartenais une famille et je dirais
largement un courant de pensée qui avait
la décence de s'unir autour du président
de la république est au tour du
gouvernement pour penser que ces
rejetons sécurité nationale
on peut faire des critiques mais pas ses
critiques qui sont roborative
je dirais et qui sont des critiques
plutôt politicienne est plutôt très à
droite voire même d'extrême droite
puisque je vois qu'une partie de ce qui
est repris par laurent wauquiez par
exemple faisait partie des propositions
soient de monsieur dupont aignan qui
soutenait madame le pen soit de madame
le pen ceci dès qu'ils sont populaires
ces propositions des républicains
60 c'est un sondage qui le donne quand
ce sont des français par exemple
interné préventivement les fiches et s
est plus dangereux c'est la formule de
garant wauquiez en quoi ça ça vous
semble que nous sommes dans un état de
droit et qu'on interne pas les gens pour
un oui pour un non puisque vous savez
que sur le fichier s il y a beaucoup de
personnes il ya différentes catégories
de personnes sur le fichier s est que
parfois il y a des gens qui sont en
cours d'examen si je puis dire qu'ils
ont été dénoncés par un voisin parce
qu'ils ont trouvé que il avait une
attitude bizarre ce qui est utile mais
ce qui peut parfois se révéler inexactes
alors on interne pas des gens comme ça
pour un oui pour un non on est dans un
état de droit
ceci dit il faut utiliser tous les
moyens qui sont en notre possession bien
sûr pour essayer de prévenir au maximum
ses entraîneurs odieux et on a eu les
explications dans différentes articles
de presse de vos confrères et cetera sur
ce personnage qui était suivi parce
qu'ils avaient des relations avec des
gens qui étaient suspectés il n'était
pas lui même suspecté directement bon
voilà alors le drame est là c'est
dramatique pour les familles c'est
dramatique pour notre pays c'est
dramatique pour la france je fais
confiance bien sûr au président de la
république et au premier ministre pour
comment dire faire en sorte et je vous
ai expliqué qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'attentats déjoués que nous continuions
à préserver à la sécurité des français
donc nous sommes évidemment un état de
droit vous le rappeler donc on ne peut
pas interné préventivement des des
suspects mais par exemple valérie
pécresse rappelle que dans le code pénal
l'intelligence avec l'ennemi est
condamné ça c'est une mesure qui
pourrait s'appliquer vous dites qu'il
faut appliquer toute la loi telle
qu'elle existe aujourd'hui est ce qu'on
ne pourrait pas appliquer cette loi là à
canton avec l'ennemi pour ramper pour
les passer en jugement faire passer en
jugement quand on a des preuves d'un
engagement avec la enfin intelligence
avec l'ennemi comme vous citez la loi
bien évidemment ces gens sont
immédiatement incarcéré c'est absolument
évident et jugés est ce que la droite là
encore a raison de faire le lien entre
ce qui s'est passé samedi à paris et
l'immigration
non on peut pas faire de généralités
jamais parce que ça conduit à des excès
toujours alors bien entendu ce garçon
est un tchétchène
il est arrivé en france avec ses parents
ses parents sa mère a été naturalisé il
a bénéficié de cette naturalisation
donc je sais bien que c'est quelqu'un
qui est venu de l'étranger d'un pays en
guerre
bien évidemment donc qui a il a été
accueilli dans notre pays
bon voilà je sais mais ça veut dire que
tous les mets dire que tous les immigrés
les immigrés ou ce qui demande d'asile
la ville vont devenir des gens qui vont
s'engager
dans avec l'état islamique ou le jihad
je veux dire c'est c'est quelque chose
d'horrible d'imaginer cela
cela donne du coup du grain à moudre au
front national qui passe son temps à
dire que l'on naturalise des gens qui
sont des immigrés période dans
l'histoire où il ya des gens qui étaient
montrés du doigt et si on avait suivi
l'opinion publique
peut-être que il n'y aurait pas eu des
mouvements
comment dire de résistance comme il y a
eu et qui ont permis de sauver l'honneur
de la france
mais comment faire pour rassurer les
français juste sur cette histoire de
naturalisation pour leur faire
comprendre que nous on naturalise pas
n'importe qui et potentiellement des
gens qu'ils peuvent commettre des actes
terroristes d'air parce que dans
l'opinion publique
malheureusement ça influe aussi mais
parce qu'il ya des gens qui portent un
comment dire un discours de confusion et
qui se mélangent tout et qui aident à
développer en france un sentiment ou
qu'ils exercèrent ben un sentiment de
haine contre l'étranger
mais regardez là merkel en allemagne il
a ouvert les frontières de l'allemagne
hans et en lui a rendu hommage pour cela
elle a changé son discours elle a dit
qu'il y avait un danger potentiel évolué
non mais personne n'a jamais dit en
france qu' on lui a même dit le
gouvernement l'a dit que des terroristes
pouvaient s'infiltrer dans mes
mouvements de migrants ça a été dit bien
évidemment mais globalisé et faire un
avis général c'est dangereux
pariant jacqueline gourault la loi ad
l'immigration que vous avez défendu qui
a été récemment votée n'empêche pas un
nouveau calé cette fois ci à paris on a
un campement sauvage qui grossit dans le
nord-est de la capitale
anne hidalgo standing à vous d'agir
exhorte-t-elle et c'est ce qu'elle dit
au gouvernement et la mairie de paris la
maire de paris soupçonne une violence et
une volonté de laisser pourrir la
situation
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez je
réponds que quand on a voulu créer des
centres d'orientation et qu'on a essayé
de comment dire de savoir qui étaient
les gens qui arrivent et d'examiner leur
situation pour savoir d'où ils venaient
s'il demande est là
6 et migrants économiques etc on a eu
des cris d'orfraie de la droite comme de
la gauche pour essayer d'organiser un
petit peu le contrôle de l'immigration
et de voir ceux qui étaient en capacité
de passer je dirais sous la procédure
asile et de demander l'asile et ceux qui
étaient des clandestins de migros ont
appelé ça fasse moi j'ai jamais dit ce
mot là c'est vous qui le reprenait c'est
tout simplement des endroits où on
pouvait examiner la situation de ces
gens qui arrivent en france
donc la loi est votée la loi a été votée
il faut donc qu'on laisse les
associations le gouvernement s'occupe et
individuellement des migrants des deux
lits des migrants qui demandent l'asile
des migrations qui sont des migrations
d'autres pays qui sont pas forcément des
migrations demandant l'asile
il faut laisser au gouvernement le la
possibilité de faire son travail ce qui
empêchera je dirais cette population
parfois désespérés qui ne trouvent pas
de solution être à être dans la rue et
vous savez qu'on a créé aussi beaucoup
de places d'hébergement
on a doublé les places d'hébergement de
marie sur les quais effectivement dans
le ce qui fait dire à 2500 résidants qui
dorment sous des tentes qui sont rivés
ce bord de l'eau de noyer mais vous
savez vous savez que c'est très
difficile parce qu'il ya des gens qui
sont dans des centres d'accueil et il ya
des gens qui partent parce qu'ils n'ont
qu'une idée c'est par exemple de passer
en angleterre il ne veulent pas rester
dans les sens parce que ils ont peur
qu'ils soient orientés vers d'autres
centres et qu on les éloigne par exemple
vers d'autres régions de france où ils
seront plus loin du passage pour
l'angleterre
tout ça n'est pas simple tous année
compliquée
tous les gouvernements successifs ont
essayé de trouver des solutions y
compris le gouvernement auquel madame
hidalgo auquel appartenait enfin était
dans la majorité
donc je veux dire c'est assez comment
dire
stupéfiant parfois de voir ces critiques
venant de responsables
l'éthique important la maire de paris ou
d'autres personnes qui viennent de
s'exprimer qui donne l'impression que
subitement tout ça est arrivé ex no
depuis quelques mois le problème de
l'immigration est un problème européen
un problème qui s'est énormément
développée et c'est un problème grave
important qu'il faut traiter avec
sérénité et avec unité dans la nation
deuxième partie tout de suite de
l'épreuve de vérité et c'est charlotte
gauthier qui va vous poser la question
[Musique]
alors une question que se posent tous
les français parce qu'ils sentent la
chose venir c'est qui va payer la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation 26
milliards d'euros à trouver 20 milliards
pour moi mais le chiffre exact ces 20
milliards si c'était dans le rapport qui
a été commandé à deux parlementaires de
chypre
c'est déjà énorme sur 10 20 cas ça fait
déjà de nombreux milliards à trouver
quelque part et les français s'en
inquiète alors qui va payer
alors il faut trouver bien sûr pour
l'instant c'est un dégrèvement donc les
10 milliards prévus pour sur 3 en 1 qui
concerne 80 % des français avec un
dégrèvement de 30 % la première année 60
% plis 100 % la troisième année c'est
l'état c'est inscrit dans la trajectoire
du budget qui a été voté pour 2018 et
les 10 milliards sont pris par
dégrèvement par le gouvernement mais pas
ceux nourris genoux les qui a fait des
économies par ailleurs maintenant le
président de la république a
effectivement décidé d'étendre la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation à
l'ensemble des français
ce qui fait que jusqu'à 2021 il y aura
disparition à partir de 2021 pardon il y
aura disparition de la taxe d'habitation
et ça fait 10 milliards supplémentaires
il faut trouver donc pour le bloc
communal puisque c'est le bloc communal
qui touchent la taxe d'habitation à la
fois les communes et un peu
l'intercommunalité lorsqu'il ya des
taxes additionnelles
il faut trouver une ressource
bien sûr après 2021 et il y a plusieurs
propositions qui sont faites dans le
rapport de monsieur bur et richard qui
basent sur une réflexion en deux parties
est-ce qu'on donne un impôt local avec
capacité de taux de la commune
et de l'intercommunalité ou est ce qu'on
donne une part d'un impôt national comme
on vient de le faire pour les régions
avec la tva ou d'ailleurs un mix des
deux parce que la ressource peut être
compensée par un mix à la fois d'un
impôt local et d'une part nationale d'un
impôt bon comment ça va trancher comment
ça va être tranchée et bien nous avons
un contact avec les élus représentatif
en france et les parlementaires le 10
sept
c'est à dire cette semaine c'est à dire
la cnt la conférence nationale est à
être des territoires où le rapport but
richard va être présentée par monsieur
bur et monsieur richard en personne et
on va commencer les discussions avec
l'ensemble des représentants de la cnt
alors vous êtes vous mis alors comme
ministre est attaché à ce que réclament
tous les lmr c'est à dire l'autonomie
fiscale nous sommes bien d'accord madame
go et wi fi nancière oui et donc alors
ça veut dire un peu l'autonomie fiscale
donc la possibilité pour les mères
demain de faire varier les taux amis de
la boue alors non on va pas du tout pas
du tout un bon jour on cherche toujours
qui va payer
non alors est ce qui est vous savez déjà
je me permets cyr on a un peu de temps
en 2010 on avait déjà eu cette opération
avec la suppression de la taxe
professionnel vous rappeler la la
suppression de la taxe économiques qui
avaient été remplacés bien évidemment on
avait déjà fait je crée des passages de
des passages au nom des passages de
collectivités à d'autres par exemple ce
qui est envisagé je vais aller plus loin
c'est que la taxe sur le foncier bâti
qui est un impôt local avec tôt et est
perçu aujourd'hui par le bloc communal
et par les départements donc il y a un
sujet qui a été mis sur table avancée
aussi c'est ce que je voulais vous dire
par le comité des finances locales qui
est présidée par monsieur laignel qui
est le vice président au sein de
l'association des maires c'est une idée
qui a été proposé par monsieur bur et
richard c'est de faire passer le foncier
la part de foncier bâti qui revient
aujourd'hui au département de le faire
passer au bloc communal
c'est très complexe on ne peut pas la
conférence des territoires ici on
aimerait savoir si effectivement est ce
que les français vont payer
c'est ce nom alors les français non
puisque sera pas d'une collectivité à
une autre il n'y a pas d'impôt mélodrame
ont fortement de coûts mais bien ses
fautes relevées est vont pas être
contents il faut trouver l ressources
nouvelles
prendre les départements c'est
évidemment est ce que ce n'est pas un
beau de la cavalerie finale sont à
jacques avait à ne pas du tout c'est pas
de la cavalerie mais vous ne me laissez
pas cessé de l'actuel manque la finance
mais c'est technique évidemment mais la
finance locale c'est comme ça qu'on a le
temps d'expliquer il ya des impôts qui
sont touchés qui sont perçues par le
bloc communal et par les départements
presque plus parler région les seules
taxes locales pour des régions c'est la
carte grise donc il faut entre les deux
collectivités entre mairie et quentin
communes et intercommunalités d'une part
et département il faut équilibrer qu si
vous passez la ressource de l'un vers
l'autre
il faut trouver bien sûr une nouvelle
ressource pour les départements et
naturellement il y a d'envisager dans le
rapport du richard la part d'un an
au national et ou la tv avait coûté en
vtt le sénateur les républicains roger
karoutchi qui lui évidemment s'inquiète
pour le financement des infrastructures
communales notamment l écoute
il va bien falloir trouver une
compensation alors on est en train de
nous dire ah oui mais on fera une
réforme de la fiscalité locale
oui bon d'accord ça veut dire quoi il
faudra bien que quelqu'un si vous
enlevez aux communes aux départements 26
milliards qui construit les écoles qui
construit des routes qui construit des
crèches qui construit les cantines qui
qui va le faire avec l argent avec l
argent il a raison de s'inquiéter
mais il est la raison et j'aurais dû
regarder ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure
roger karoutchi que je connais bien qui
était ministre
en 2010 si ma mémoire est bonne avec
nicolas sarkozy quand le président de la
république a décidé de supprimer la tp
qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a trouvé aussi
des ressources en a bougé comme je
voulais dire entre les collectivités et
c'est très bien
n'est ce pas que le gouvernement fera en
sorte bien sûr parce que c'est assez
simple que les ressources des communes
et des intercommunalités
soit il en tirera des identique
la taxe foncière est ce que il faut
s'attendre à un distinguo entre gars
taxes foncières des résidences
principales et secondaires est ce que
les propriétaires des résidences
secondaires vont être ceux qui vont pas
qu'ils vont payer tout simplement alors
par un argument de nommer social du
reste la taxe foncière et la taxe
foncière tout le monde la paix mais où
est ce qu'il est ce qu'il y aura une
surtaxe pour les propriétaires de
résidences secondaires et ce qui a été
dit c'est ce qui a été dit c'est que la
taxe d'habitation ne serait pas
supprimée pour les résidences
secondaires et les locaux vides
là aussi il faut comment dire trouver le
moyen
alors soit on laisse la taxe
d'habitation telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui soit on la remplace par
autre chose mais ça n'est pas décidé ça
mais c'est vrai il y aura une taxe sur
les résidences secondaires et sont les
locaux vides bon d'accord allez on
change peut-être de sujets avec un autre
sur un autre sujet polémique
sur lot la vision constitutionnel oui
peut-être est-ce que vous êtes prête au
bras de fer avec votre ancien collègue
sénateur gérard larcher parce que lui a
l'air bien décidé à ne pas lâcher les
droits du parlement
lui considère qu'il y as affaiblissement
avec cette révision
on va l'écouter risque est là il il
avance ses arguments très critique
effectivement notamment sur la dernière
mouture qui lui est parvenu sur les
côtes le président du sénat pour résumer
on conditionne le droit d'amendement
on vide son utilité la navette
parlementaire on préempte l'ordre du
jour je vois pas comment on peut nous
expliquer que ces dispositions ne vont
pas dans le sens de l'affaiblissement du
parlement bicaméral et de leur
concentration du pouvoir par l'exécutif
la question c'est donc prête pour le
bras de fer
madame bourreau des bons je connais bien
le président du sénat je pense que le
président du sénat est dans son rôle
bien sûr en défendant la chambre haute
et il l'a dit dès le début de
la réforme constitutionnelle qui je le
rappelle avait été annoncé haut et fort
par le président de la république
pendant sa campagne présidentielle parce
que parfois aussi il est bon de redire
les bases de la discussion
le président de la république et gérard
larcher se sont vus beaucoup revu
beaucoup il se parle souvent et il parle
de réforme constitutionnelle toutes les
semaines il ya des périodes où il est
évident que la et l'autre ne sont pas
tout à fait sur la même position et
encore aujourd'hui son avis est ce
qu'aujourd'hui au sénat de droite et est
ce qu'un accord est possible pour éviter
le référendum
le sénat est de droite oui le sénat et
de droite avec un président qui a été
élu aussi avec des voix radical
centriste
c'est à dire que nous sommes dans une
assemblée qui n'a pas il n'y a pas un
parti comme c'est pas à vous je vais
dire cela qui a la majorité à lui tout
seul c'est déjà c'est le résultat tout
simplement d'une dose de proportionnelle
au sénat et il est évident que il y à
une représentativité plus grande ce site
a une partie des centristes n'est pas
très content non plus de la tournure
qu'a prise la révision constitutionnelle
ils s'en sont exprimés également je sais
je sais je les il montrait des faux
négatifs
vous savez moi j'ai aussi mes camarades
qui me téléphonent
il fallait au niveau temps froid ce
n'est pas possible c'est d'avis
politique moi je suis devant une
émission de télévision je lui dis pas ce
qu'il faut il faut lire il faut pas
croire que chacun est chez soi et
personne ne se parle pas près de pouvoir
sauver cette réforme et éviter la
location moi je crois que
je crois que nous avons intérêt bien sûr
tous et y compris le sénat que cette
réforme réussisse je pense que le sénat
a intérêt à ne pas apparaître comme un
élément bloquant d'une réforme annoncée
par un candidat à la présidence de la
république un président donc élu et qui
applique son programme
oui mais c'est au prix d'un
affaiblissement les parlements aix puis
après il ya des débats parlementaires
et enfin quand je dis y'a un texte il ya
trois textes via le test consiste
yonnais la loi organique et la loi
simple et donc tout cela fait partie de
discussions et de débats parlementaires
qui font que on avance au fur et à
mesure aussi du temps et des discussions
de confiance mais je pense qu'il ya des
choses quand même que le président a
évoqué tout à l'heure sur la procédure
législative
c'est vrai qu'il y à cet article dans le
texte constitutionnel qui concerne la
procédure législative que c'est beaucoup
que c'est important mais moi j'étais
sénateur suffisamment longtemps pour
savoir que nous avons besoin de
moderniser la procédure législative et
je pense que vous qui êtes dans cette
maison vous savez bien aussi qu' il y a
des choses à faire évoluer
qu'aujourd'hui depuis 2008 nous avons
deux semaines réservées aux
gouvernements et de semaine réservé
l'une à l'initiative parlementaire
l'auto contrôle du gouvernement je pense
et tout le monde sait que dans les deux
semaines initiatives de contrôle de
gouvernements
ça n'est pas les plus fréquentés et que
parfois on aurait bien aimé avoir un peu
de temps pour finir un texte etc
donc il y a une possibilité de le faire
moi je trouve que c'est une avancée de
la vie démocratique
quant à la navette parce que ça c'est
aussi
l'important aujourd'hui un texte
effectivement on peut passer à plusieurs
reprises en navette entre les deux
assemblées ce qui est prévu dans le
projet de loi constitutionnelle c'est de
limiter
après l'échec de la cmp c'est à dire
déjà après une première navette de
textes de la limiter à une fois au sénat
et une fois à l'assemblée
je veux dire ça n'empêche pas la navette
c'est à dire qu'il aura déjà eu quatre
études du texte il faut replacer les
choses je dirais dans le dans la le
juste de ce milieu justement si j'allais
bien
l'une des mesures qui fait débat
également c'est la part de députés qui
seront élus à la proportionnelle donc le
chiffre était retenue de 15% et c'était
le thème de notre première question du
sondage opinionway pour l'épreuve de
vérité est bien pour 60% des français
15% députés à la proportionnelle ça ne
changera rien et alors quelle est votre
réaction sachant que 60 % des français
pensent comme françois bayrou qui dit
que c'est totalement dérisoire et lui il
en voulait 25%
oui et d'ailleurs l'acteur porno enfin
pour ce cadre et son nom est dit qu'il
faudrait plus les 60% disent que ça
servira à rien qu'il faudrait plus de
députés à la proportionnelle
le problème de la proportionnelle c'est
mathématique si je puis dire parce que
quand vous faites une liste à la
proportionnelle et que vous mettez un
certain nombre de députés donc ce sera
60 je crois est bien évidemment tous les
partis sont représentés dans la
proportionnelle et les plus grands
encore si je puis dire
après le scrutin uninominal et petits se
rendre encore plus marginalisées
généralement soit bayrou aurait aimé
effectivement que lier une
proportionnelle vos cibles et plus et 25
%
je suis de cette famille politique via
su la convaincre le président de
remettre de cette famille politique
en même temps comme vous savez il y a
des obligations d'avoir un député par
département il y a des principes
constitutionnels aussi où vous pouvez
pas y est le fameux tunnel des 20% entre
les circonscriptions les plus voilà il
ya des tas de contraintes qui ont fait
que le choix du gouvernement s'est porté
sur ce pourcentage
là encore n'est ce pas c'est un texte
qui va être discutée puisque c'est pas
le premier texte
comme vous le savez la proportionnelle
c'est pas dans le texte constitutionnel
bon c'est un taxi va être discutée et
s'éteint c'est une base de départ s'est
passé dans le marbre les espoirs de
réussite moi je suis vous n'allez pas me
voulaient pas me mettre dans un corner
je suis modem veut bien sûr jeu
je ne m'en cache pas je suis solidaire
du gouvernement auquel j'appartiens très
bien donc vous n'êtes pas dans le corner
mais voilà vous essayer de concilier les
deux positions on a bien compris la
suite de l'épreuve de vérité avec la
troisième question que va venir vous
poser maintenant paul briat
[Musique]
vous êtes modem mais vous êtes
solidaires du gouvernement alors est-ce
que vous avez des impatiences comme le
dit le modem d impatience sur le volet
social de la politique du gouvernement
je je crois je ne suis pas sûr que
françois bayrou a utilisé le mot
impatience mais alors après quelques
jours il a enfin le temps j'ai lu comme
vous l'article
linkedin par les yeux des parisiens leur
il a appelé surtout à un nouveau modèle
social c'est surtout ça qu'il a défendue
c'est à dire l'idée qu' on ne peut plus
se contenter d'un système qui donnait au
fond des allocations aux gens qui
étaient dans des situations difficiles
et ces allocations ont prouvé par le
passé que cela n'était pas toujours des
solutions efficaces surtout quand les
allocations n'était pas lié à un projet
personnel un projet professionnel et
donc l'idée de françois bayrou c'est
d'appeler à un haut-fond un nouveau
modèle social et ça correspond tout à
fait est d'ailleurs à ce que veut faire
le président de la république car comme
vous le savez je ne vais pas vous faire
un scoop c'est que françois bayrou est
le président de la république emmanuel
macron sont très proches se voient
souvent et 10 coutu régulièrement
c'est pas parce que françois bayrou
s'exprime quand il s'exprime pas en 10
ou est il que fait-il il ne soutient
plus le gouvernement quand il s'exprime
et qu'il avance ses idées et ce qu'il
ressent on dit tiens est ce que par
hasard ils ne seraient plus d'accord
avec le président de la république
mais si ceux signés françois bayrou il
est d'accord mais le nouveau modèle
social c'est tout à fait ce que veut
faire le président de la république est
ce qu'il a commencé à faire je pourrais
citer plusieurs mesures qui ont été
prises
courageuse par exemple pour la baisse
des charges sur l'emploi pour que dans
le bas de la fiche de paye il y ait des
ressources qui sont soit supplémentaire
même si je sais que c'est une
participation sur la csg des retraités à
tous les retraités puisque 40% des
retraités ceux qui sont les moins
comment dire les moins dotées ne sont
pas touchés par ce prélèvement de la csg
et cliquer en parallèle il y à la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation dans
une politique équilibrée
c'est une c'est une pluie c'est pourtant
avait pas perçu comme ça le gouvernement
crée saison pour exister donjon cause de
l'augmentation diminue l'augmentation du
minimum vieillesse
l'augmentation de la prime de la
location pardon adultes handicapés tout
cela ce sont des décisions qui ont été
prises et qui vont se mettre
effectivement progressivement en place
alors il faut mesurer que c'est vrai que
certaines mesures qui ont été prises et
appliquées dès le mois de janvier vont
être compensée comme la taxe
d'habitation ce qu'on paie seulement en
septembre sauf les gens qui sont
mensualisées alors c'est peut-être un
problème de communication que souligne
d'ailleurs françois bayrou il il n'ya
peut-être pas eu assez de pédagogie sur
ce qui a été trop comme moi je suis la
pédagogie est quelque chose d'essentiel
absolument très important et il faut
sans cesse en faire moi je les ai vus
par exemple pour la taxe d'habitation je
reviens dessus
vous savez que je participe à beaucoup
de congrès des maires évidemment il y
avait toute une parole portée par des
opposants qui avaient fait croire que au
fond c'est une perte sèche pour les
communes
voyez que il n'y aurait pas de
dégrèvements fait par l'état
il faut faire de la pédagogie sans arrêt
donc vous dites emmanuel mâcon n'est pas
le président des ch
c'est une fausse idée à je suis
absolument persuadé de cela bien
évidemment et je pense que il y a eu une
volonté politique d'une opposition de le
faire croire et qui a été sans cesse
répétée donc nous notre travail en tant
que ministre c'est de répéter sous ce
qui est fait sans arrêt et je pourrais
citer d'autres choses encore
comme vous savez la participation dans
l'entreprise c'est pour 2020 on fait pas
tout d'un coup parce qu'on on a aussi un
budget de la france qui est ce qu'il est
et encore une fois nous l'avons eue
comme il était moi je vais pas faire
comme la politique politicienne trouve
c'est de la faute d'avant mais en tout
cas c'est une situation qui vient du
passé
alors vous mettez en cause l'opposition
qui fait son boulot peut être une façon
vive peut être radical est ce que vous
êtes inquiète quand vous voyez je ne
sais pas certains mouvements éclore dans
le pays
aujourd'hui on voit par exemple qu'il ya
des actes de
weill ans à la sncf il y a le mouvement
des étudiants qui semble se transformer
petit à petit en mouvement de blocage
des examens vous qui êtes au ministère
de l'intérieur
est ce que vous y voyez des signes
inquiétants je vois des signes de
perturbations et des signes sûrement
d'organisation politique
d'extrême gauche d'extrême droite qui
essaient oui de déstabiliser au fond un
peu le pays et qui ne respectent pas la
démocratie quand on empêche les
étudiants d'aller passer des examens
alors que 70% des étudiants voudrait
passer leurs examens et disent qu'ils
sont favorables
au fait de continuer leurs études
sereinement
il y à un sujet effet une sujet est un
sujet qu'il faut traiter avec fermeté et
on voit comment les présidents
d'université etc sont là pour protéger
leurs étudiants et demander si besoin
est
l'intervention des forces de police pour
faire respecter la loi et gagne il faut
faire respecter la loi et faire
respecter la volonté de la majorité
la démocratie c'est ça également dans
les gares quand les cheminots viennent
les bloquer comme on a pu voir la
semaine dernière par exemple vous qui
êtes au ministère de l'intérieur vous
pensez que il faut faire peut-être à
l'avenir plus intervenir les forces de
l'ordre oui sans les cheminots jeu
je ne sais pas de quoi vous voulez
parler exactement mais à la gare
montparnasse me semble-t-il la semaine
dernière et ceux de tête monsieur l'âge
ailleurs et est intervenu oui il ya des
actes de malveillance il faut faire
respecter la loi
on est dans un état de droit comme je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure pour d'autres
sujets on quand on parlait de
l'immigration on est dans un état de
droit et quand vous viens d'écouter le
droit de droit mais qu'il y ait des
corbières justement de la france
insoumise qui va à prêter main forte à
des étudiants qui bloquent les examens
et vous estimez que ça mérite une
réaction
je suis très choqué pourquoi finalement
les députés il aiguille la nuisibilité
populaire qu'est ce qui empêche d'aller
soutenir des combats qu'il estime juste
et bien il peut aller défendre des
combats qu'il estime juste mais il peut
laisser ceux qui au d'autres combats
exerçaient leur combat c'est à dire leur
combat pour avoir une formation pour
avoir un métier et peut-être pour payer
leurs études
ce n'est pas la place d'un élu d'après
voilà et bien qu'il manifeste ses
propres idées et qu'ils les expriment et
qu'il empêche pas les autres d'aller
passer enfin les étudiants d'aller
passer leurs examens
quand enfin bon je ne sais pas moi même
j'ai un petit fils qui travaille l'été
pour payer ses études
qu'est ce que c'est que ça on va
empêcher des jeunes de passer leurs
examens
mais c'est antidémocratique c'est contre
la jeunesse sa mére des sanctions par
exemple de l'assemblée nationale le
comportement de alexis corbière en soit
je laisse le président de l'assemblée
nationale
à ces responsabilités mais je trouve
scandaleux que des députés empêche
effectivement la démocratie de s'exercer
alors
emmanuel mac on n'est pas aménagé sur
par le par l'opposition et notamment sur
les questions internationales ont il
nous reste quelques minutes pour en
parler si vous êtes d'accord ggyc 0 on
lui reproche finalement échoué dans ses
tentatives et là c'était le thème de la
deuxième question de notre sondage
opinionway
est ce que vous estimez que la sortie
des états unis de l'accord iranien est
un échec pour le président français 63%
des français disent oui et vous
effectivement
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire c'est que le
président de la république
emmanuel macron a fait tout ce qu'ils
pouvaient tout trop peut-être
mais se trompe non tout ce qu'il pouvait
pour essayer de persuader monsieur trump
de ne pas prendre cette décision
monsieur prennent trump a pris sa
décision mais on peut pas reprocher au
président de la république française est
tout de même
c'est pourtant ce que dit par exemple
son prédécesseur françois hollande qui
dit avec monsieur 3ème pont qu'on ne
peut pas faire cette stratégie de la
séduction ce sont les termes de françois
hollande est ce que emmanuel macron un
petit peu à l'image d'angela merkel
n'aurait-il pas eu intérêt à se montrer
plus ferme moins familiers avec donald
trump vu que résultat n'est pas très
concluant je ne sais pas lequel des deux
a été familier d'ailleurs mais toujours
est il qu'on peut noter qu'il y a une
différence fondamentale et nouvelle de
la présence de la france dans le monde
et que ça on le doit à emma le manège
macron qui a redonné à la france sa
place dans le monde et qu'il a un
principe c'est qu'il parle avec les
responsables de se montre et que même
s'il n'est pas d'accord avec les
responsables de ce monde
ils essaient toujours de leur parler
pour que la situation ne dégénère pas et
ça c'est une marque de fabrique si je
puis dire des manuels mâcon il n'a pas
peur il l'a dit d'ailleurs dans son
discours quand il a reçu le prix
charlemagne
il ne faut pas avoir peur de la
mondialisation et quand il dit ça il y à
cette idée aussi derrière il faut aller
au devant les chefs politiques et des
responsables politiques pour parler avec
eux et essayer autant que faire se peut
bien évidemment de les influencer
pour l' équilibre du monde et la paix du
monde et bien ça c'est tout à fait
respecté ce qu'il ne faudrait pas parler
plus fermement puisque la stratégie de
la discussion sur un ton de
compréhension on a vu beaucoup d'image
de donald trump et d'emmanuel mâcon
presque dans un cadre en tout cas dans
un cadre cordiale si ce n'est amical qui
ont pu d'ailleurs un peu interrogé
certains
est-ce qu'il faut changer de discours de
tonalité en plus aujourd'hui il ya eu
quand même plusieurs dizaines de morts
en palestine avec le changement de le
transfert de l'ambassade des états unis
à jérusalem
donc on sent que les choses sont en
train de basculer dans cette partie du
monde
est-ce qu'il faut pas voilà changer de
registre tout simplement je ne vois pas
ce que vous voulez dire quand vous dites
qu'il faut changer de registre
il faut mais madame ou mademoiselle
pardon je ne sais pas il faut mesurer
que la france joue un rôle déjà
primordial dans le monde que nous
faisons des efforts sur le plan
militaire qui sont considérables et qu'
il faudra également que l'europe soit
plus forte et c'est aussi ça le discours
qu'a fait le président emmanuel macron
il y à un moment où il faudra bien que
l'europe dans son ensemble pense à peser
plus fort et plus lourds sur l'ensemble
du monde à l'image de ce que emmanuel
macron veux faire c'est la manière dont
on permettra de montrer l'universalité
de la france et de l'europe et de
l'europe
merci beaucoup jacqueline gourault
d'avoir été avec nous merci de très
bientôt
[Musique]